calling both of those games with kenny
albert hopefully
fully hydrated so he does not uh cramp
up at any point over the next several
hours
pierre maguire kind enough to call in
from the edmonton bubble how are you sir
richard welcome to the nbc family great
to talk with you again i'm really jacked
up
obviously uh hydrated very well hydrated
rick so
ready to go and uh you know what it's
quiet in the bubble right now honestly
it really is
i think it's just the calm before the
storm to be honest with you calm before
the storm let's start with the first
match
uh first match up the avalanche and the
dallas stars
uh a seventh game right here um
walk me through what you're expecting to
see in this one pierre
you got to get to your game first riff
so if you're the colorado avalanche you
want to get to your speed game early you
want to spend a lot of time in the
offensive zone
you don't want to be defending for long
periods of time and because if you do
you're playing to the strengths of the
dallas stars which is
get it in ground and pound four check
the heck out of the colorado defense
get bodies in front of michael
hutchinson who's only getting his third
ever
nhl career playoff start so you want to
do those things if you're dallas be
aggressive be smart
don't take penalties play to your
strengths colorado
get to your game of speed and skill and
dexterity still
both keeps having to get to their game
quicker than whomever does
which i think has the best chance to win
this game
uh vegas and vancouver playing
on consecutive days why why that pierre
can you walk
everybody everybody has to play one
back-to-back
and if boston had gone to a game seven
boston and tampa would have had to play
two back to back
so it's for competitive fairness to be
honest with you
um and that's why but everybody has to
play back to back in the uh
in the second round that was just the
way it was set up before we
got to this um you know situation so
it's an imperfect situation right but i
can tell you
nobody's dealt with an imperfect
situation better than the national
hockey league
this is perfection personified by
commissioner bettman
bill daley i'm so proud of the people at
nbc
uh and i can tell you this the health
care professionals the hotel workers and
the players
rich it's been unbelievable i'm telling
you i've been in pro i've been in the
nhl for 32 years
i've never been more proud of our league
ever well it's been unbelievable well
it's been it's it's great to see
you know what i mean it's great to see
and not have to wonder if anybody's
clean or
um or sick it's it's it's it's been
great to see
and again tonight um this kid between
the pipes for vancouver
um he's only the third rookie goalie to
force a game seven with a shutout and
now he's gonna have to try and do it
i mean it's truly amazing from san diego
thatcher
demko again though when you got a hot
goalie that's good news but
back to back that's got to be something
pier
it sure is rich and you know i'll give
you some background on him he's a
tremendously athletic young man
his mother was a world-class volleyball
player at
the university of florida his father was
a college basketball player his brother
has played pro soccer in san diego
he's a kid that when he was 15 years of
age at a us hockey
usa development camp in rochester new
york the great scottie bowman saw him
play there and told me
at that time that he thought this kid
was going to be spectacular
my first uh meeting with him was when he
was at boston college playing for the
hockey hall of famer
jerry york and uh i was blown away by
how good thatcher was then i know the
men that recruited of great brown is now
an assistant coach
with the rangers and mike kavanagh who's
a head coach at university of
connecticut
and they both told me when they were
recruiting him how great this guy was
going to be so it's not like he just
fell off the turn-up truck a lot of
people that have tracked him for a long
time
really thought that he had greatness in
him and he's showing that they were
right
and they all were right and then let's
get to the the third game seven
that's going to be coming up this
weekend um between the flyers
who have uh forced a game seven with
their
third overtime win of the series that
flyers have never done that before
in a same series a two overtime win over
the islanders who do you think has the
advantage in this seventh game
you know momentum usually doesn't carry
over rich in a playoff series but in
this one
for the first face-off momentum is
clearly on the side of the philadelphia
flyers just because of
how they won their game six to force at
game seven
so the islanders better get on their
horse in a hurry and not allow
philadelphia
to dictate the terms with some of their
bigger people like kevin hayes
and not let the philadelphia defense
make a difference in terms of
manufacturing offense from the defense
if philadelphia is allowed to get
physical early
not take penalties and take some of the
speed
that's the problem with the outers but
the momentum will have really gone from
game six to game seven but if the honors
get their game going early
uh with speed and score early i think
they have a little bit of an advantage
so
again it's a little bit like colorado
and dallas whoever gets to their game
first
uh probably has the best chance to win i
know it's not your bubble pier but i
mean what is
what does tampa do in a bubble just
chilling in toronto i mean just
honestly they might go a full week
without playing a
a game looks like there's if you weren't
you know what rich i gotta tell you i
lived in toronto for a couple years and
obviously over the years i've coached a
lot of games here and broadcast a ton of
games there
it's an awesome city when there's no
bubble right i go to a lot of good
restaurants
and there are a lot of good clubs to
hang out in but in the bubble it's a
little different the one thing i'd say
again
tip of the hat to the nhl in particular
and the players association
um they've found day trips for these
players to do they've given them places
to go green space to where they go where
it's still part of the bubble i have not
been in the toronto football boxes
here for a long time uh since august
27th
so i've seen how our bubble works and
i've heard really good things about the
toronto bubble but i haven't been there
right so i can't speak to it have you
ever called two games in a day ever
many times at the olympics in fact the
olympics i've done
three uh for nbc i've done two men and
one women's game or two women's games
and one man's game so
i've done a lot at the olympics at the
world junior when i was working for a
canadian
network tsn i did sometimes three and
four at world junior
and uh during this uh bubble experiment
here in edmonton rich i gotta tell you
kenny albert and i
have done uh every other day we did
three games so
a day so we've we've done uh two for
sure and sometimes
i guess that's a silly question because
i have watched you do multiple games in
a day but i guess never game sevens
would be the way to put it no that would
that's the best way to do it and you
know what kenny and i were talking about
that walking on by the way rich i know
you know kenny well of course what an
amazing partner to work with
well i mean he comes from he comes from
good stuff he comes from good stock i'm
in this business because of his dad
you know just he's growing up and
watching truly
one of the best bus rides i ever had was
with marv albert rich
uh going to the rio olympics we sat in
the back of the bus and we just talked
about the new york knicks
the new york giants and the new york
rangers
man i would have loved to fly on that
wall hey pierre again
uh hydrate get get ready to call two
game sevens uh one on usa
and then the next one on nbcsn four
eastern stars in avalanche game seven
and then at nine eastern on nbcsn
canucks
and golden knights you take care of
yourself we'll chat uh as uh the chalice
begins to become more into focus
thanks a lot richard welcome again to
the family great to have you on the same
team
hey man that's really nice you to say
that that's uh pierre maguire
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here